we need a money-making product that can
launch this business so while they carry
on learning with my assistant G I'm off
to test out some recipes
I've got a hunch that combining some
childhood favorites of mine might just
give us the edge lemon curd for me
growing up as all that little bill mmm
luxury and it tastes delicious
so first up a classic with a twist lemon
curd treacle tart Jamie into the oven
yep carefully you can see I got tray
that place yeah okay
why do I wanna do it hard way huh and
using the lemon curd base again for a
different spin on a bake well it's gonna
stuff for me that I grew up with but
mummies do run a little tea house called
the cobweb tea house professional and
the only thing I ever wanted was either
carrot cake bagel tart or treacle tart
it was so delicious it may work it may
not work it may be too lemony
you never know unless you try so thank
you - Carla's prawns bashful about
mutton fried burger yes really how long
for that child the big rolls not quite
the unique taste I'm looking for the
product I feel could have selling power
is the lemon treacle tart
[ __ ] delicious sorry lemon curd it's
cuz that double
double-double deliciousness Sammy
honestly it's rich its creamy and it's
just wow that works
I think this tart is the kind of
standout product we need to build a
business on so today I'm taking my
biggest gamble yet I'm not only going to
put the tar to the test so it's a
hundred little loaves cool cut them in
half scones 100 I want to take advantage
of everything the boys have learn to
bake so far and sell it all in bulk to
the public
yeah we've got the best kitchen of
Brixton here just got to get fired up
everything's got to be full if all these
ovens are full in an hour's time no yeah
off you look more relaxed when you go
buy this it's for prisoners or shouldn't
be given a chance between like that
especially with the crime rate gonna
supposedly is that good look pcs in the
British public and we are gonna be
telling them everything you buy here has
been made by prisoners okay so the bad
boys bakery is born